je disais que ce soirêtre un bon soir
pour faire l'amour tu crois
pas c'est une idée intéressante mais VO
est
je St le nouvel opé avance
bien discussions on doit recevoir un
prier jet partition dans
semain malureus
cré
[Musique]
mal il se sent bien il s'est totalement
écroulé après son dernier
opé je peux
pas tu as besoin d'une bonne marche il
faut que tu Seces pour Ceres mauvaises
habitudes inter AC je dois y aller j'ai
impati
bye on va par là je continue de vous
imagine je ne sais pas si vous voulez
que je vous donne plus de détails
non je que chacune de ces personnes a
une histoire digne d'un
op tu fais quoi Jeile bateau
remuais ce bateau est une arme
mortelle
romtisme arrê pour
harclementiv une
thérapie je suis pas censé faire
ça j'ai du mal à croire ce qui est arriv
c'est
une Sorre la capitaine qui at les hommes
sur son remqueur pour les
[Musique]
tuerangesoutétais vraiment colère contre
toi là je découvre que je
suis je teit
j
j'
deant j'im j'entre dans le tte boute
deésinectant je fais un
mén ta capitaine de bateau est venue me
voir je suis amoureuse non non tu
refuses d'avouer que j'ai eu un effet
magique sur toi mon imagination a
inventé l'histoire mon talent à composer
la musique est-ce que je sache tu ne
tues pas les hommes pour les dévorer et
bien pas
encore tu sais que je peux pas résister
à une belle histoire d'amour même si je
suis pas
[Musique]
concerné